sin muy buenas noches pues ahora la
asamblea legislativa del estado de nueva
york es la que tiene el poder como quien
dice para poner encima de la mesa un
juicio político llevan desde marzo
recopilando información y esto sumado a
la investigación que ha realizado la
fiscal general del estado de nueva york
ha dado lugar a que ayer se reunieran
para trazar digamos una hoja de ruta y
cuál va a ser el calendario en caso de
que ese juicio adelante ese juicio
político siga adelante como seguiría
adelante ese juicio político pues bien
esa es una decisión que se tiene que
tomar desde la cámara baja del senado
estatal del senado de nueva york perdón
y son los legisladores quien lo tienen
que decidir como lo decidirían con una
mayoría simple bastaría con 76
legisladores a favor de los 150 que la
componen la mayoría de ellos son
demócratas y más de dos tercios ya
habían dicho que si como no renunciaba a
su cargo estaban a favor de que se
celebrase ese juicio político ahora con
este giro este cambio que ha dado la
situación habrá que ver si todavía
siguen defendiendo que se celebre ese
juicio político quien sustituirá como en
la gobernación de nueva york'
sí como comentaba es en 14 días esa
renuncia se hará efectiva y le va a
sustituir la vicegobernadora casi 8 que
además se va a convertir en la primera
mujer en llegar a la gobernación del
estado de nueva york en la historia 8 y
tiene 62 años y su cargo debería
mantenerse hasta el 1 de enero del 2023
ha dicho que se encuentra perfectamente
preparada para convertirse en la
gobernadora número 57 y también ha dicho
que celebra la decisión del gobernador
andrew como recordemos que ya se había
manifestado en su contra como lo han
hecho otras figuras del partido
demócrata la mayoría le han dado la
espalda al gobernador andrew como el
propio presidente joe biden y el domingo
por la noche una de sus principales
asesoras quizá esto unido a esa
investigación por parte de la fiscalía
de nueva york ha sido lo que ha empujado
al gobernador andrew como a tomar una
decisión que aquí nadie se esperaba de
hecho un alto funcionario de la casa
blanca ha dicho que ni siquiera la
administración de bailén estaba al
corriente de esta decisión
cuál es la reacción de las mujeres de
las víctimas porque él renuncia pero no
admite ningún crimen
así es las víctimas se encuentran
aliviadas han hecho un comunicado
conjunto en el que celebran la decisión
que ha tomado el gobernador andrew como
dicen que están felices de que no pueda
seguir utilizando esa posición de poder
para acosar a otras mujeres lo han
celebrado también sus abogadas han dicho
que es la decisión correcta y que ha
celebran además esto que os comentaba de
que por primera vez en la historia de
nueva york va a ocupar el puesto de
gobernador a una mujer